[Music]
you have a collect call from an inmate
at hillsborough correctional facility
veggie hey you want us to come get you
no no listen i got my truck
hey
[Music]
i got steaks i got booze i got beer
we are hanging out tonight
[Music]
bought a new tv huh i did i mean much
bigger but what
you said you got in did i get in how's
early acceptance
you know someday i'm gonna make a lot of
money that you don't have to work so
hard okay juicy when she goes to ucla
she should get a degree in marketing or
something what do you know about it it's
called social networking my balls got
social
networking it's good all of us thinking
[Music]
hey what's up it's frank
yeah you just uh you just keep going on
93 north for a while and then you'll uh
you'll see my shop it's the uh only
place for this light on who's coming
over frank oh this kid he's come by
[Music]
meet my voice
guys this is chad walker
[Music]
hey entertain our guests please
i got a story for you look at that
what are you talking about out there
maybe joking about something what do i
do here
i've been working in the shop for over
10 years trying to give my daughter a
future
what the hell's going on here frank
ruined crystal's life we're gonna kill
him
father is gonna soothe the [ __ ] out of
you
oh we gotta get out of this you didn't
think about it
i wanted tonight to be special
[Music]
you